العالم المجتمع الدولي يجب ان يجد طريق ما
لحل الازمه في اوكرانيا بمعنى استمرارها
اكثر سيؤثر على العالم وتداعيات وسط ستطال
دول اكثر عالميا هل ترى ان هناك اي جهد من
اجل المساعده لانهاء هذه الازمه ام ان
الموضوع هو كل طرف يريد ان يتزوج بالسلاح
اكثر من الطرف الاخر ولا يوجد ضوء في
نهايه هذا النفق
على تجارتها صغرى وهذه الحرب لم تسر كما
توقعت روسيا فهي تدخل شهر الثامن او
التاسع
فقد يكون هناك توقف القتال لكن ليس توقفا
في البؤس وهذا الامر بكل تاكيد يعني انه
بعد نهايه الفصل
القوه الغازيه»
بان النظام الدولي يشعر بحاله من الغموض
روسيا هي دوله القضيه في مجلس الامن
التابع للامم المتحده ولها صلاحيه في
البيت
ولم نرى اي حركه من قبل الاسره الدوليه
حتى اللحظه لوقف فيها من هذه الصلاحيه ولا
اعلم اذا ما كان هناك ضوء باخر قبل ثلاثه
اشهر سنه نناقش مساله امدادات الحبوب وقبل
ثلاثه ايام كنا نناقش هذا الامر لان
الرؤوس
اليوم
انضمت روسيا مجددا الى اتفاقيه تصدير
الحبوب العالميه بواسطه الامم المتحده
الامريكيه
90%
ايضا لهذه المنطقه